characters of mandelas aren't they well
we're joined Now by Royal biographer Tom
Bauer Tom great to see you you've got
this Blockbuster book I've been reveling
in your extracts very juicy stuff first
of all your reaction Prince Harry
popping up at the United Nations of all
places on Nelson Mandela day preaching
away about climate change again having
apparently got there by private jet
again
um preaching about politics in America
which no Royal's supposed to ever do so
the Constitution's been wound back and
so on
um whining about sort of the terrible
painful year he's had and all the rest
of it what do you make of this why does
he do this what does he think he
achieves by it well and also saying all
that work to do in Africa which you
dedicate his life to but prepares now to
paddle in the Pacific in Santa Monica
well he does it because he needs a
profile that's the only way they can get
money by sharing the profile and for
Netflix everything is built around
around the future documentary series to
promote the sussexes when you're as
rankly hypocritical as Harry is you know
preaching about climate change using
private jets all the time when he
doesn't have to
is there not a point where the United
Nations should avoid using people like
him on a Mandela day for example well it
was pretty empty the auditorium wasn't
it it was quite interesting and the
United Nations is quite famous for being
a center of hot air so I think it's the
right place on this day but it was
unbelievable was I mean Mandela's Legacy
was really betrayed by the South
Africans and you know South Africa could
have been a completely different country
of Mandela had been able to live for a
few more years yeah and I just thought
that he skitted over all the problems of
Africa and the self-inflicted problems
while he just lives in luxury Montecito
and he made he made reference to Mandela
20 times in this brief speech clearly
trying to draw some kind of parallel
between his own struggle and Long Walk
to Freedom it's this great inspiring
historical figure who literally spent
three decades nearly in a tiny cell yeah
well you know because you're the first
person to say how limited the Prince
Harry is unfortunately
oh and now his wife trades off her
husband's fame and fortune or not
something Fortune now I mean this is the
problem but we're still interested
because afterwards he's a great
character in our modern day we can't
ignore them if they keep popping up
doing stuff like this we're kind of in a
mutually abusive toxic relationship
aren't we the media and Harry and Megan
because they keep doing stuff wanting
attention then they get quite adverse
reaction most of the time then they
react really badly to the reaction and
so it goes on what is what it really
boils down to is the threat they offer
if the threat was punctured which I hope
my book will do and if their importance
is diminished which I hope my book will
do is show what really any lawsuits yet
normally no too early too early it won't
be long it won't be long uh stay there
so I'm going to come back and talk about
your book after The Break uh where
princessy and woke and Harry must be
nuts were apparently the reactions from
Harry's friends after their first
meeting with Meghan Markle and those
were the ones we can repeat eat but some
of the revelations in Tom's explosive
you but Revenge we'll talk about that
afterwards I'll go back to PS4 now since
Tom Bauer is a man in every public
figure fears when he puts his literary
Talons into them this time it's Harry
and Megan it's a great revelations in
here
um let's just go through some of them I
mean the one that really stuck out to me
because I'd heard this from actually
some of the people that you were talking
about is when Meghan Markle goes to meet
Harry's friends for the first time and
they're all his old mates from the Royal
days they've all been to eat and most of
them and so on and they have a kind of
certain banter which Harry used to
thoroughly enjoy pretty sexist and
misogynist and so on and so on and
they're spraying around all their normal
jokes and Megan is picking them up on
every single one and it's driving them
nuts yeah well this is a Sandra a
weekend shooting party which was quite
normal for Harry and he just thought
they'd all get on together but in fact
the opposite I mean Megan is someone who
doesn't hold herself back from
complaining about people's way of manner
their way they talk the way they behave
and all the rest of it she has a
narrative and she's a very dominant
daring woman and so she asserted herself
and what was music was on the way home
from Sandringham they're all texting
each other oh my God what a nice Nutter
how on Earth can he stay with her and
the same then happened when they went to
Tom inskip's wedding in Jamaica which is
a friend a great friend of Harris who in
the end was banned from the dinner after
their wedding yeah well quite I know I
know at least three of the very good
friends were apparently banned by Megan
and then they saw all these celebrities
filing it exactly who'd known her about
three minutes if that and Megan was
really she controls everything so it was
a great Cameo tell me about uh the Queen
the queen apparently your report didn't
want Megan Phillips Funeral why well she
was she didn't want to be the attention
diverted from Philip if Megan had been
there she would have got all the
attention I mean the Harry walk up the
hill with uh William was that just
showed how the media was focused on the
reconciliation and everything after
Oprah so when she said to one of her age
thank goodness Megan isn't coming she
meant it was a heartfelt was it the
queen that kicked him off the balcony at
the Jubilee well I think it was the
queen but also I'm sure Charles and
William had a big say in that they
weren't going to allow Netflix to
dominate their their big celebration
when are we quite a few of the anecdotes
and the extracts there's a lot of
diva-like behavior from Meghan Markle
very controlling about her image when
she does a Vogue shoot for example all
over it uh exactly how she wants it to
be Vanity Fair all these things there's
a constant kind of feeling that she
wants to be completely on top of
everything and anyone who gets in her
way he gets trashed well she thinks she
wants to be the great Hollywood
celebrity the style Meryl Streep or
something like that she imagines she
should do the same the problem is she
gets undone on each occasion on vanity
Affairs she doesn't get at all what she
wants although she gets much more than
can be expected but of course then the
palace react because she's behaved
appallingly by not telling the palace
what she's going to do and I think the
most interesting story is the rightness
story reitman's is like a Marks and
Spencers in Canada and I got the most
enormously exciting story from the
people involved in the shoot for the
advert 80 strong cars and crew who tell
this story about a woman who is after
what only paid fifteen thousand dollars
a day peanuts for a Star to advertise
these very cheap clothes under a hundred
dollars a pair of clothes and as she
behaves accordingly and they're all
loather at the end and she walks up in
the end with a pair of shoes they
thought they'd lent her when you when
you got to the end of the book did you
have any sympathy for Meghan Markle did
you buy into her thing that she had no
idea what she's really getting into oh
on the country I think she's a very
scheming very uh clever woman no I think
the surprisingly at the end of the book
I realized how successful she'd been
here is a woman who was nothing I mean
born broken family the whole thing uh an
act an unknown actress all the rest of
it becomes a global star which is what
she wanted when she was about to nine or
ten she said to her father I want to be
famous I want to walk down the red
carpet and she has now done that and
she's calculated that she could be a
great success and and by marrying her
Harry she did it and so are they in
trouble now though is the Sussex brand
on the downwards so a lot of American
friends of mine are completely done with
them which they weren't you sure and
this made this book May hasten a
downward Trend yeah I've always had at
all because they pose a real threat to
the royal family that's what I've felt
from us the reason I've been so
exercised about them is I think they are
destroying a lot of the magic of the
monarchy that they're calling the Royals
a bunch of callus racists and so on
without producing any hard evidence to
support any of these countries and it's
incredibly damaging actually turning
untruths yeah and I think that was
terrible that's really why I wrote the
book because I just thought this woman
is really doing something quite Dreadful
to Britain and Harry has fallen in love
with her you know there's a ludicrous
way and has gone along as her accomplice
what about Thomas Markle in all this
he's he's had a big stroke I'm told he
can't even talk at the moment he's not
heard a word from his daughter he
brought her up for years on his own
wasn't at the wedding for reasons we all
know but what's your sense about him
well I went I went down to Mexico and
spent two days with him and of course
you can't have anything other than
sympathy for a man who was terribly
reduced by his daughter and quite
puzzled and what the book tells is how
that descent into accurately happened
which I don't think has been told before
and it all really the Genesis is these
Paparazzi pictures which you know the
Genesis is along with four pills is it
oh much longer when she's in Canada
she's already breaking off from him Oh
you mean between yeah between him and uh
I meant actually probably between Harry
and Megan as a soon to be married couple
it seemed to be all blew up because yeah
he has his pathological hatred of
Paparazzi no no why did Harry never go
to meet Thomas why is that well I think
because uh Megan didn't want him to meet
a fat old man I mean Megan was very
worried that's why she brought her
mother across the way in just two days
before the surgery what do we know about
her mum her mum's a mysterious the book
tells it all I mean the mother really
was a very odd woman disappeared 10
years effectively during her childhood
that's why Thomas had to bring her up
and in the end what Thomas says is that
it was Daria who really engineered the
split between himself and Megan because
she wanted the fame and the glory
strawberry situation where you have
Megan completely split from all her
family on both sides apart from the
mother and Harry now pretty much split
from all his family the two of them
living in this weird place in California
this big house and pretending or
behaving like a renegade royal family
whereas that I mean the the rise of
Montecito but what is interesting is
that right at the beginning Samantha
Markle Thomas's uh daughter warned
everybody she said she's breaking our
family and she'll break the royal family
too we all laughed at her and it was
true yeah it's a fascinating book
Revenge by Tom Barr Megan Harry and the
war between the Windsors it's going to
be a bestseller isn't it so it is
already appears so
other than the weather right now good to
see you thank you very much